- [Instructor] We are told
the differentiable function h
and its derivative h prime are graphed
and you can see it here, h is in blue
and then its derivative h
prime is in this orange color.
Four students were asked to give
an appropriate
calculus-based justification
for the fact that h is increasing
when x is greater than zero.
Can you match the teacher's
comments to the justifications?
So before I even look at
what the students wrote,
you might say, hey, look,
I can just look at this
and see that h is increasing
when x is greater than zero
but just by looking at the graph of h,
that by itself is not a
calculus-based justification.
We're not using calculus.
We're just using our knowledge
of what it means for a
graph to be increasing.
In order for it to be a
calculus-based justification,
we should use calculus in some way.
So maybe use the derivative in some way.
Now, you might recognize
that you know that a
function is increasing
if its derivative is positive.
So before I even look at
what the students said,
what I would say, my
calculus-based justification,
and I wouldn't even have
to see the graph of h,
I would just have to
see the graph of h prime
is to say, look, h prime is greater than,
h prime is positive when
x is greater than zero.
If the derivative is positive
then that means that the slope
of the tangent line is positive
and that means that the graph
of the original function
is going to be increasing.
Now, let's see whether one
of the students said that
or what some of the other students wrote.
So can you match the teacher's comments
to the justifications?
So one student wrote, the
derivative of h is increasing
when x is greater than zero.
So it is indeed the case that
the derivative is increasing
when x is greater than zero
but that's not the justification
for why h is increasing.
For example, the derivative
could be increasing
while still being negative
in which case h would be decreasing.
The appropriate justification
is that h prime is positive,
not that it's necessarily increasing
'cause you could be increasing
and still not be positive.
So let's see.
I would say that this doesn't
justify why h is increasing.
When x is greater than zero,
as the x-values increase, the
function values also increase.
Well, that is a justification
for why h is increasing
but that's not calculus-based.
In no way are you using a derivative.
So this isn't a
calculus-based justification.
It's above the x-axis.
So this one, what is it?
Are they talking about h?
Are they talking about h prime?
If they were saying that h
prime is above the x-axis
when x is greater than zero
then that would be a good answer
but this is just what is above the x-axis
and over what interval?
So I would actually, let's
scroll down a little bit,
this looks like a good thing
for the teacher to write.
Please use more precise language.
This cannot be accepted as
a correct justification.
And then finally, this last student wrote,
the derivative of h is positive
when x is greater than zero
and it is indeed the case.
If your derivative is positive,
that means that your original function
is going to be increasing
over that interval.
So kudos, you are correct.